why do I not play games
why just don't be bad don't play video
games
I don't watch PewDiePie but I keep
seeing thumbnails for his recent videos
and does he play video games just
PewDiePie even play games any Mouse just
pip I even still play real video games
or he is just trying to be random and
funny by saying offensive [ __ ]
member member went through the past used
to play good games all lifeguarding was
a good game for you oh I'm sorry I
missed ill I'm heavily disappointed I
missed when you used to play games my
miss voted by playing games where the
goddamn games got [ __ ] down hey hey
hey let's go calm down
in 2016 we played some [ __ ] awesome
game inside uncharted 4 there Walking
Dead Season 3 fired fire watch and I was
one episode better Last Guardian yeah I
think that was the best Bayonetta my own
Atta yeah that's right we played the
game uh-huh okay okay well if you want
game so [ __ ] badly you just have to
[ __ ] it and scroll down here click here
and oh my god there should be a couple
thousand videos for you there you're
welcome
Oh undertale we played undertale 3481
videos I'm pretty sure there's plenty of
gameplay for you out there
actually before I start this video I
just want to say thanks a lot that
sounded very sarcastic but I she said
thank you guys so much for all the
support on my last video about Forge
positivity it's kind of like a sensitive
topic I don't know
but whether you agreed with me or not I
really appreciated the sense of
sensibility since yeah from you guys I
didn't really expect it to blow up so
much I do it's literally just a topic
that I thought a lot about and I guess
you can say this video will kind of be
like a part two to that because game's
name [ __ ] games basically one thing
that I brought up in that video was that
I used to kind of fake that I was really
enjoying a video game because I thought
more people would enjoy watching it that
way and so I would play a [ __ ] ton of
games that I couldn't care less about
just because I knew it would get me
views on YouTube and that's pretty much
I think I think that's pretty much happy
will for you please like super popular
games like no one is playing happy
wheels in 2017 and actually enjoying it
I refuse to believe that and I think
it's same with Minecraft like these
games were they're just so popular so
people play them regardless if they
enjoy them or not and I I thought I was
at a point where I'm like okay well I
shouldn't have to do that anymore and I
think people people speed through I
that's another thing I didn't really
mention talked about in the other video
as well as that I think you guys are
smarter than that as well and I think
you can tell if I'm not really having a
good time playing game you can see that
so that's why I don't play a lot of
games that I used to play and my finds
are kind of pissed off at me for it
there's just no way to win if I play I
lose if I don't play I loose so I might
as well just go and be selfish and think
about me because yes it is my job to be
to entertain to entertain you guys and
if you guys are entertained with me
playing happy wheels then maybe I should
just shut the [ __ ] up and do it but I
also think you guys don't want a fake
version of I think it's
I think you guys want me to be on I
think we all everyone on YouTube kind of
put up a fake version of themselves
alright or a different version of
themselves like literally every youtuber
I met speaks differently to you rather
than to a camera I think that that's
pretty normal but it's [ __ ] true to
everyone I think that's fine but I also
feel like I want to when I talk to the
queue guys I want to be a version of me
that feels genuine it I don't want to go
a happy with ah even though it would get
me more views and I know and I know no
one's gonna believe me when I think I
don't think views is everything stupid
life
I think happy waves is kind of like okay
it's so it's such a funny game don't get
me wrong but like all the gore and all
that [ __ ] it's funny for a while but
then it's like the same joke over and
over and over and over and it's just
like okay well it's clearly not funny
anymore and if you still think it's
funny then you clearly faking it and I
think it's the same thing with like
smash and I think that's why I hate that
game so much is because yeah the first
game was really good and really scary
but it's the same [ __ ] jump-scare
over and over and over and if you if
you're still playing it and still
enjoying it I think you're clearly
faking it from use it for such a
repetitive game like you get the jump
scare okay if you enjoy it for like that
the gameplay or story or whatever I
think that's fine but people people want
to see me play snap just so they I can
get scared with a jump scare but I
refuse to fake a [ __ ] jump scare
because it's so [ __ ] stupid and the
game is absolutely not scary whatsoever
to me and then I played it on YouTube
and I took the video down because we've
got so pissed that I wasn't scared or
playing the game so I told I'm telling
you guys you want games but at the same
time you don't want games so what the
[ __ ] do you want from me alright I'm not
a monkey alright you can
dance all you want them but I won't
dance I'm gonna [ __ ] dance for [ __ ]
I'm gonna be on it I don't even play
games that much by myself anymore I used
to play so much [ __ ] game I swear to
God I have liked it more than 365 days
spent in world of warcraft
I got [ __ ] 2000 hours in modern
warfare 2 which is sort of hard to see I
don't even know how many hours I spent
playing tibia I wasted so much time
playing those games but I [ __ ] loved
it I have some of my favourite memories
playing game so don't get me wrong I
don't know something has changed I don't
know if YouTube kills games for me but I
there's so many games that I genuinely
want to play like overwatch but I refuse
to play them because I just know I've
been there before I had the experience I
played the game
hope it's funny [ __ ] I don't know where
I'm going with this
god damn it I feel like I had the
experience with games before and I don't
want to just keep it I want to
experience other things okay I want to
experience the things that my parents
told me when I was little and said it
while I was playing video games hey put
a clown why don't you play an instrument
they call me PewDiePie when I was a kid
hey why don't you read a book hey why
don't you just go out and play with your
friends like all those things I
genuinely want to do now instead of
playing games like here's a list of
games I made a list that I haven't
played yet but I know I will [ __ ]
love hyper light drifter The Witcher 3
fallout 4 gazelle the Wind Waker HD Dark
Souls 3 I didn't finish it doom
overwatch Dishonored 2 some ro3 stardew
valley all born battlefield 1 Metal Gear
Solid ok
alright you get the point and that's
just last year I really want to play
this game and I know I would [ __ ]
love playing them but at the same time I
haven't played them and I think the main
thing is time it was like I know I could
spend the time playing the game and I
know I would [ __ ] love them and I
know what everything would be great but
it's like I've been down that road oh
I'm talking like I'm an addict I think I
might be I think that's why I'm talking
like this
I think I just realized I'm addicted to
video games now I think I'm past it I
think I'm I I want to experience other
things in life
it's what I'm trying to say at least in
my spare time and I don't know if
YouTube is the thing that ruined it for
me but I write I don't know I know it
sounds crazy but I'd rather just read a
book I'd rather just play an instrument
all these things my parents told me to
do I am now doing them deliberately what
the [ __ ] what is wrong with me
what the [ __ ] YouTube you ruined it for
me you ruin games for me YouTube gasps
damn I don't know I'm 27 I'm not that
old I here's the thing I know I will
always love video it's just one of those
things but I think I want to tone it
down a bit just to do other things as
well I want to try out different things
and it's not just for my channel it's
also kind of personal I know it's sad
it's just sad this whole comes the tool
covers this whole video it's decide
another reason I haven't been playing
video games as much on the channel is
that I feel kind of limited whenever I
play a game like if I have a different
tone than what's going on in the game
that's really annoying I find that very
annoying when there's a Miss michmash
like if there's a sad moment in the game
and I'm just going like ah that's my my
own my impression of myself by the way
I'm kind of limited to what the game is
doing alright I gotta follow the flow of
the game if I'm just recording whatever
other video I have so much more freedom
I can do whatever I want and I'm really
enjoying that freedom what I've been
doing is kind of just waiting for games
that I know will make sense for me to
play and just focusing on that that's
why I will always keep playing games on
this channel but I rather just space
them out a long thing I have to enjoy it
you guys have to enjoy it can't be too
short can't be too long like I would
love to play persona 4 but that game is
so [ __ ] long they wouldn't work on
YouTube it has to be somewhat
interesting for people to actually want
to watch it and click on it like there
was this game this war on of mine which
looks amazing and I really wanted to
play but I know like no one would click
on a game called this war of mine and I
and then that's the thing like well I
should just play it anyway right because
I really want to play it
and so what is if some people don't
watch it but at the same time if people
don't want to watch what I put up on
YouTube then why don't I just play it by
myself
something struggle just keeps going on
and I don't know it has to be a match it
has to work and there's not that many
games coming out that fits and it's kind
of [ __ ] hard and if you start a game
and you never finish it then you're
still going to hear people [ __ ] about
it for years
Felix weren't Alice in Wonderland why
haven't you finished that game well it's
been four [ __ ] years Jesus Christ I
got bored I'm sorry I'm [ __ ] sorry
there are games coming out I just need
you guys to be a little patient okay I
think that's the best way to do it I
mean well I'm just gonna have to put up
with these [ __ ] comments about
where's Pia play do play gives a dirty
with the gaming channel
I think 2017 for me the year where I'm
just going to be painfully obvious and
one thing I know for sure is that people
don't like honesty even if they say they
do and I think that's why I got in so
much trouble lately with all the drama
and all the [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz I haven't
been censoring myself as much as I
probably should but I've been really
enjoying it personally and I think I'm
at the point in my youtube career where
I can afford to be honest and maybe
loose a couple people and have the
people that watch me appreciate at least
that I'm true to myself and if they're
in it in a way at least that isn't too
dishonest does this make sense to you I
can't really tell it's kind of weird for
me to make this video but yeah either
way if you did understand what I was the
[ __ ] I was saying thank you and thank
you for supporting me and watching my
video I've been loving the past weeks
you could despite like cut out all the
drama that's happened spending some of
my favorite weeks on YouTube I'm having
a lot of fun games are coming just be
patient
I promise I would never ignore you I
love you yeah thanks for supporting me
it means it honestly means towards me
and I'll see you in the next gameplay
video check it out here if you
check out another video meanwhile it's
going on I'm going to do prophecy it
sticks beer next time let's speed up I
see you next Wednesday
[Music]